The "G.I. Joe" movie franchise has been missing in
action, but if there's one guy who can rescue it,
it's the ninja known as Snake Eyes. The character
is returning in an all-new series reboot;
here's everything you need to know
about "Snake Eyes: G.I. Joe Origins."
The first bit of news about the "Snake
Eyes" movie that the public heard came
out over three years ago, way back in May 2018.
At the time, the Hollywood Reporter confirmed
that Paramount Pictures had put into development
a "G.I. Joe" spin-off film centered around Snake
Eyes, tapping the live-action "Beauty and the
Beast" movie screenwriter Evan Spiliotopoulos
to pen the script and Brian Goldner to produce.
The outlet also noted that executives at
Paramount and Hasbro had been keen on rebooting
the "G.I. Joe" franchise, and had commissioned a
writers room dedicated to developing movies and
cinematic universes around the Hasbro properties,
including "G.I. Joe," "Transformers," "M.A.S.K.",
and "Micronauts." By all accounts, the
"Snake Eyes" solo flick was one such
idea - and according to an interview producer
Lorenzo di Bonaventura gave to Entertainment
Weekly in 2021, it was one of the only solid
ideas that writers room happened to produce.
Things were relatively quiet on the
"Snake Eyes" front until December 2018,
when Robert Schwentke signed on as
the film's director. Audiences will
know Schwentke as the director behind
movies like "The Time Traveler's Wife,"
"R.I.P.D.," "The Divergent Series: Insurgent,"
and "The Divergent Series: Allegiant."
In 2010's "G.I. Joe: The Rise of Cobra" and
2013's "G.I. Joe: Retaliation," the Scottish
martial artist Ray Park played Snake Eyes. In
December 2018, "G.I. Joe" franchise producer
Lorenzo di Bonaventura confirmed with Slashfilm
that Ray Park wouldn't be reprising his role
for the character's origin story, leaving
the possibilities for the movie wide open.
It wasn't until mid-2019 that the "Snake Eyes:
G.I. Joe Origins" cast started to come together,
and a few more months after that
before the movie kicked off production.
So, if Ray Park isn't Snake Eyes, then who is?
That'd be Malaysian English actor Henry Golding,
whose performance as Nick Young in the beloved
romantic comedy "Crazy Rich Asians" has led
to roles in the feature films "A Simple Favor,"
"Monsoon," "Last Christmas," and "The Gentlemen."
Through "Snake Eyes: G.I. Joe Origins," the
talented actor will be taking on his first
leading role in an action movie, and he has
a heck of a supporting cast surrounding him.
"Snake Eyes" also stars "Ready or Not" and "Bill
& Ted Face the Music" actress Samara Weaving
as Scarlett, a fierce G.I. Joe agent who also
works for Clan Arashikage; "Money Heist" star
Úrsula Corberó as the Baroness, a member of the
terrorist organization Cobra; Peter Mensah of
"Marvel's Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D." fame as Clan
Arashikage's co-leader Blind Master; Andrew Koji
of the excellent Cinemax series "Warrior" as Snake
Eyes' friend-turned-deadly-nemesis Storm Shadow;
and Haruka Abe as Akiko, a Clan Arashikage trainee
with connections to Snake Eyes and Storm Shadow.
Rounding out the cast of "Snake Eyes" are Iko
Uwais as Storm Shadow's uncle Hard Master,
who leads Clan Arashikage; Takehiro
Hira as Cobra member Kenta;
and Steven Allerick as Snake Eyes' father.
Playing a character as famous as Snake Eyes
in a franchise as action-heavy as "G.I. Joe"
would require even in-shape actors to get
more ripped in preparation. Henry Golding,
whom no one would consider unmuscular in his
everyday life, got totally shredded to play Snake
Eyes - undergoing intense training that yielded
impressive results. In November 2020, Golding
said that he "became a weapon" during "Snake
Eyes: G.I. Joe Origins" prep, and even shared
a jaw-dropping clip from one of his training
sessions on The Tonight Show with Jimmy Fallon.
"It put me through my paces. We had,
like, four hours of choreography
every single day. We had two hours of
script work, then like an hour of PT."
According to Golding, the producers of "Snake
Eyes" went out on a limb in casting him,
having faith that he would be able to build
on his boxing and martial arts background
to become a credible supersoldier. That
bet seems to have paid off in a big way.
"It was worth it, because I became
a weapon, I'm not going to lie."
The "Snake Eyes: G.I. Joe Origins" cast
and crew began filming in October 2019,
shooting in Vancouver, Canada from
the 15th of that month to the 9th of
December. When Vancouver shooting wrapped, the
production moved to a new locale: Tokyo, Japan.
The cast and crew spent about six weeks in Japan,
and in late February 2020, Golding announced that
all principal photography for "Snake Eyes"
was complete, writing in an Instagram post,
"...and THAT, is a principal wrap
on Snake Eyes lady's and gents
What a crew we had, Vancouver + Japan, you
were unstoppable. Thank you for the dedication,
this film is going to blow
everyone's socks off x."
Initially, "Snake Eyes" was slated
for a theatrical release on March 27,
2020. Like many movies originally slated for
that year, it ended up going through some
release date reshuffling, eventually being taken
off of Paramount's release schedule entirely.
Over a year later, in March 2021, Golding came
forward with another announcement about filming:
"Snake Eyes" was undergoing reshoots.
In an Instagram post about the reshoots, Golding
acknowledged the difficulty of filming under COVID
protocols, and expressed his happiness that they
were still able to pull it off in spite of it.
"We just got some reshoots for 'Snake Eyes,' but
I'm so grateful that we're able to pull this off."
After those last minute reshoots,
the film is now officially set to
land in theaters on July 23, 2021.
First and foremost, "Snake Eyes" will be
an origin story - and as such, fans will
get to see the events that transform him into
the masked, silent badass they know and love.
In the "G.I. Joe" animated series and in the
Marvel comics, Snake Eyes' silence has been
chalked up to damaged vocal cords, but that
fact was retconned for the feature films.
Snake Eyes doesn't say a word in "G.I.
Joe: The Rise of Cobra" and "G.I. Joe:
Retaliation" because he previously took
a vow of silence following the apparent
murder of one of his masters
at the hands of Storm Shadow.
The film's story will focus on Snake Eyes
accepting an invitation to begin training
with the Arashikage, a clan of Japanese ninja.
The process will prove more difficult than
anyone bargained for, as the truth about
Snake Eyes' past comes to the surface,
his mind and heart are tested, and
his body is pushed to its limits.
Of course, with Storm Shadow as a
key member of the character roster,
there should be an epic showdown between the
dangerous man and his former friend Snake Eyes.
Remarks that star Henry Golding
has made indicate that "Snake Eyes"
will be charged with a weighty task:
rebooting the entire "G.I. Joe" film
series. During a press conference
in January 2020, the actor said,
"[The movie is] unlike anything people will
have seen. We're really starting a new timeline,
a new franchise with[in] the 'G.I.
Joe' universe. To kick it off with
such a distinct and stylized film, I think, it
really sets the precedent for follow-up movies."
While one could make the case that Paramount
and Hasbro are jumping the gun by rebooting
the series after only two films, it seems like
a smart move. "G.I. Joe" has the potential to
be a smash-hit property along the lines
of the "Fast and Furious" and "Mission:
Impossible" franchises, but it hasn't
happened yet; previous entries in the
franchise, "Rise of Cobra" and "Retaliation"
underperformed critically and commercially.
In his past comments, Golding perhaps
inadvertently pinned down one big reason for this:
a lack of personality. "Snake Eyes" can
fix that, reintroducing the franchise by
way of an origin flick for its most
compelling and unique character.
Though "Snake Eyes: G.I. Joe Origins" has yet to
open in theaters, Paramount and Hasbro executives
already have a sequel in the works. The Hollywood
Reporter broke the news in an exclusive report
on May 1, 2020, detailing that "Rebecca"
and "Seberg" writers Joe Shrapnel and Anna
Waterhouse teamed up to co-write the script
for "Snake Eyes 2." Lorenzo di Bonaventura
is returning to produce and, of course, Henry
Golding is circling back to star as Snake Eyes.
There isn't a whole lot of information about
the "Snake Eyes" sequel out there just yet,
and fans will have to wait to see the first
flick to know what might happen in the second.
It stands to reason that "Snake Eyes:
G.I. Joe Origins" could end with its
eponymous character taking a vow of silence
or venturing to never show his face again,
although doing both, while canonically accurate,
might make for an underwhelming follow-up film.
Lucasfilm's Disney+ streaming series "The
Mandalorian" proved that a project's main
character doesn't have to show their face
at all times - Pedro Pascal's Din Djarin
almost never takes his helmet off - but that
they should at least speak up every now and
then to keep things interesting. There's also
bonus points of course for the masked character
showing some wit and humor when they do engage
in conversation. How will fans feel if Snake
Eyes hides his face but not his voice, or vice
versa, instead of doing both down the line?
In any case, it says a lot that
Paramount and Hasbro greenlit a
sequel well before "Snake Eyes" debuted.
Fingers crossed that when "Snake Eyes:
G.I. Joe Origins" debuts on July
23, it'll blow everyone away.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.